eme
米にの商品全部
カッターな絵になるなぁ
ブーツお兄ちゃん安全社長です
どう思いますか分からわからないからやる
んですだけで今回ですねこちらの僕の元
バイト先の労損師吉添さんに生きているん
ですけども主義的なタイミングで改装工事
ということで今日5市で店舗お休みして
いるみたいでコンビニで24時間営業なん
で基本的に人がいない瞬間てないんです
けども奇跡のタイミングでさえい走行で
ツアーであればもう人がいないので表1に
続きります貸切て永遠の仔大都会走行ざる
ちょっと急ぎ足にはなるんですけども今
しかできないと思いましたと来て今回は
ローソンにある物を全部買ったら万円に
なるの実際に買ってみたいと思いますし
なる気ないでしょ
彫金ある在庫とかもあるんです後ろの
それも
それはやめとこうか回走行でしただーまた
タウン営業されると思うんです後ろの際
ことが抜きに清楚お店の表面に見える部分
に触れてもいいよって嘘お店の中にある
やつ全部合わせるとな絵になるかを被選挙
一人であの買い占めてみようと思います第
4夜大富豪ではないくらい融合ではないし
たら絶対やついけないので他のお客様の
迷惑になりますので今後の対応リング
そしてあのローソンさんともお話しして
ちゃんという日からも他のお客様に問題
ないよという巨漢を得てなんかないことが
挑戦したんでしょうねで向かわれるという
体で発注していると思います版をしした
状態で全部買ってみたいと思います買った
後のことも考えてあのトラックも準備させ
ていただきましたカッターも商品全部
トラック詰め込んで宇宙ご準備は完璧で
ゼミは完璧が早速工事もあると思うので
急いで買っていきましょう
いただきましょうかえっ
待って待って待って待って待って待って
[音楽]
ブーブーああああああマスクの会社のよく
ないと思うんですよ僕
確かにさすでに必要としてる人が多すぎる
姉ますがやめとこ私がこれはまだ置いとい
てもどうせ売れるもんだそうだよね嫌な人
に使って欲しいからこういうものはやめて
おきましょう
もうミドルでで言うのはね欲しいよ確かに
めっちゃ食ってるこれ全部返るって事です
だから上にも
これは e 品 e もえーちょっといや
jade リーこれ全部さ自分でタイプだ
からうわぁ
uf 夢だねちょっとぐるっと見てみます
かって普通の店舗ですねちょっと手間てぃ
だからうちの店舗っていうけど見て
くださっ相手がちょっと少なひ
あつっ
けどもったいねーから今回ちゃんとを冷凍
用の保管 box も準備しておりました
準備バッターないね裏ちょっとあのー
5分
たテレビ太郎さんすごくてか品揃え
めっきりは前列ゴイスやばいでしょこう
いうハーゲンダッツとかも高くなりそう
ですね
さすがに入ってこの並べブチ切れる思い
ますね
もうすごいすごいトップ公園等がすっごい
綺麗に入って家のローさんすごかったんで
すごいいいんじゃないよねカプラーでマジ
コレ待ちきれんだねこれウはそうなんだ
けどでうちの店もこういうなさんお客様が
変われるわけじゃないですかありがとう
ございましたって帰った後すぐってこう
やって前に出すうわーすげー全然早いか
本当に選定されましたよ
ブービーしろってずっと仰せられた
[音楽]
ティソー
アティ
[音楽]
生かし系綺麗だねーなーっ16線
チャンネルをしっかりとをあの会葬者です
今日は咽頭日で他のお客さんさんに作って
いただいているちょうどいい量で針がてい
ます
えっとちょうどいいかどうかわかんない
ですけど僕のために作っていただいたと
言っても過言ではない今日に関してはいい
ねぇいいやーいいねまたここのヘッドです
よが卵のう組の草もしっかり6幸せですね
これをんなぁジャンルを網羅しって逆に
なんだみたいになったんですけどちょっと
ぞ
てょ絶だよね買うよ
いいえ
全部4
見えてはすまじでん
[音楽]
ブーバーし
黒い
こういう言葉ですよね指で新見で黒いな
乳製品とかまた衝撃早いから the 所
右んぎりが早い物って多分食べきれないと
思う寄付で必要なものはしっかり寄付させ
ていただきたいと思いますただなるべく俺
そして仲間たちでこの後すぐ食べようと
思いますちょっとにもったいない服はし
たくないからなるものがあっても勢が
サンドイッチ
優しい俺なら全然やっぱりお客さん来ない
からさ合いすぎてもの俺今だというと思わ
れていってことをまあそうする米に感謝を
レナウンは専門外から助け唸るようなんす
かねこれ
デザートほらっデポローソンといえば
デザート9編もずっとこうシェイク見ない
ぞんだろうねどうですか県警が全部を入れ
ましたけど
これぜーんぶ0チェーンポールぞすっごい
雨よ
生活室品って言われますかマスクは
やめようまあすごい良くないあとタバコを
やめていいちょっとだけ字警笛の好きな
銘柄だけ1カートン買ってあげるよあー
やっぱけど個人的なお金でやるんですよ市
では早速買っていきましょうかはい
これがいろんな人に勝ってほしいねこれは
僕はそう思うよ1個ずつぐらい買ってみて
欲しいですよね
[音楽]
ブーブ la とかあったらまあまあよっ
ちゃあ
意識 had to
[音楽]
dome
なぜかずっと人が必要な部分の個室で
大食いたのと必要大サイズは買ってないん
ですよ
ブーブー言っ2000円ん
の分ある
やばい量があるダンボールの地味され空の
下に入れるようじゃ気合い a day
いやいやいやいや
しかも妄用意しちゃっていうかねこれだよ
これ
まあこっちしてますからほじっして買いに
来てるね今回こそんこれさー
お会計やばくないですかがちと言われてい
ますいくろ
いやちゃんとも上金準備しなりますまとめ
てバーンて会計ショートしたんですけど本
目に立ったあのちょいちょいの書いてある
んだよどちらもカーレーダー取ってくれ
ターっ
ちょちょっと何なのかわからんけどなどう
考えていますこれでなんとかさえたらいい
なっていう感じでハマっていきたいと
おもいます傷つきかぷみましょう居室
殴り合い使っていきましょうこういった各
選手の夫婦ほほ鼻やいやいやいやいや
いやいやイェーイ県産の和栗が多いって夢
だよ9名でもある意味があなたにすると
怖いよ
夢って
いやーちょっと
この1年
この何でもカゴいっぱいがになっちゃい
ます1回ちょっといっぱい運動会期世代を
お助けして行ってみましょう顔いっぱいず
んでなんとだけの愛する金額がお分かり
いただけますさあ来ましたあそこぞお
まぁまぁまぁまぁ
1,123円うんああ
おいすっやさしい
背肉100円から200円くらいなもんだ
なこれをあと何回勝っていきます
よし会津おりましたじっくりアイス
ボックス準備させていただきましたラバ一
例これで縛る貨物しろジョンシーズン
ぐらい相机ゾーンの武器がないですから
高級アイスコーナーんまぁ黒い木が
スンニョンいっぱい here を知り
たいところそれは何か現実もやりますそう
だちょっと行ってやってみろ俺んちの近隣
住民のまだ何かあったら宇津木ていただ
けど色でたくさんいますので
teeサゲんだってカップで囲い込まれ
ましたさせてこの影君なるとこの夢の量で
これだけミティ
これは気になる
[音楽]
649目なあ
まあそうてるんですか
漕艇界
僕もちょっと覚えていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
ha
loop
冷凍食品
おりましたこっちつをな c もちろん
らしいぞ
いや
[音楽]
表面だけで深さすごいよこれ売ればにょ
ゲル狩るのは1分
[音楽]
実機たくさん狙いかな持ってそのこっちは
お願いしまーす
ちょっ
シャーンっ結構冷蔵系デザートとか乳製品
とか出したんだけど見てたからねん
結構多くなってきたねこういう子ザートっ
て本当に超しか持たないんでちょっと
ほんと終わり次第で急いで
ています
みんなでよしデザートコーナー破ったんで
次はここですね心にとか最強釣りの羽根と
いけない気もしてるかな風のどこ1付いて
ます俺はじゃあですね
ちょっとほぼ全部行きます march
ってそうです動くんですけど a 8
net んだっいろいろ嬉しいで外交際
もうもう大丈夫だし困っちゃってっ
うわぁそれ
好きだわープレッシャーを全部の皆さん
いた
マスクなくてありが zepp なんか
これさー
5悪いん
[音楽]
よしどうでしょ冷蔵の飲み物が終わったら
次は冷蔵としょっです冷蔵の去ろうとの
散歩でもするし
[音楽]
これも教授っぽいですねーザバーン弁当家
はなんか早い f
ここは僕の専門外とっても米ですよね
わたってください再定義で冷蔵のこの一番
コンビニの端このやつ全部買いました
ごらんください方だ
ありがとうございました
すごいよねなんかイベントおきたいこれ
これはねーフジロックあったね
はい快おりましたはい多分ここがメイン
でしょお菓子コーナーで動いよ昔の行組
だけでもどれを謳歌する
今日はもうすごい種類ある10やばいよ
当分コーナーだ
糖分のバランス当分困らんからうまえねー
ちょっともうこのありとあらゆる汗が
これをそれで最初見ていきたいとおもい
ます
rar
[拍手]
[音楽]
whですええええ
笑顔頭のメイン乱れからおりますさあが3
分の1が良いからだ
[音楽]
一人でありますよねまずようにいませ
詰め込み作業しておりますさっきのパター
の冷凍と冷蔵今トラックに積んでます俺ん
ちばっていますこのまましばらく俺んちも
アイス屋さんになるからとしくんみんなき
てね駄目だった絶対ダメでしたら頃すっ
すごい量やねぇ引っ越し容易に
んっ
を取ったcar
[音楽]
よっしこのトラック脱退やれば終わるの
でしょうかおかしいぞ全て入れましたココ
を見て
パンダネットチョコがもう全部なくしまし
たもうちょっと動かしあるんでそこだけ
入れちゃいましょう
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー皆さんきん
ヌーコンビニまたこういうちょっとした
tips リポ4
プロ
[音楽]
スパーダイングランダー氏
tar両下肢まひと通称にペットとした
まあ
暖かいねえええええええ
ブーブーんっに行きましょうかハイ協議で
続いては我々エナジードリンクコーナー白
サティあれだけですが上がればあれだけ
言っ
行こうかんっ
meそれだけ3 t いっ
1ペンチ性の高いじゃん気になるところで
はありますね
あってヤバイよマジ
やばいよさーい
[音楽]
窮地をにて
3万見てやっぱり栄養剤とかダサいんだよ
だからも元気だねーな疲れちゃったんだぞ
機内を持っている普通になるこの経文が
乗ってくれ松井いった壁ばじゅんさんが
待ってなんだけどダメ花のほどいいって
もんじゃないから
ほぼてりーなもんなぁレッドブラーの暑い
夏2
厳しいよタップ言えなくなってこんな苦労
するとわんこっ弾いと立派なすべてか言わ
れましたこれは個人的に買って嬉しかった
たくさん取得したこれで編集頑張ります
me
ああああああ
nar ん
en
ん
dai
emeんん
持っ
ていたいいいい酒でもありましたよ
だーそうといきましょうかこのベストない
んじゃなかったけどビッグマンとかから
英文とかお弁当とかあるんですけどついに
あのセリフがありますおおいいですか
じゃあ
あの
ここまでの場でもらっていいですかああ
これを言いたかった彼はさあ高く大丈夫
意外と大丈夫そう
まあ一番くらいから予想はそれこそその
時間限られてますからまずで今日ずには
食べないと部分が終わったら続けます us
て付けば損なし
2つの6人からしてチックでもらいたいん
10年
10個
競ってこそ
でキャラクターグッズもう通学売れそうだ
ねーそうですねラン時間経ちました6時間
経過せます6時間ずっと一人打率くれて夢
やっぱ版といったかいかないかぐらいで
このままだと配当公人に多く会が出て
しまうという感じですよええまずいですね
これは
なぜはちょっと本当にません改装工事に目
は桜でいいんじゃないんでご休憩なしで
パーてと間に合わないとか分かってきたん
でちょっと色んな人に協力してもらい
ながら会計始めていきたいとおもいます
頑張りますという
持っています
まあ当然で the していきますどうし
たらコンビニもうよくあるこの dvd
コーナーとかも全部買います僕のユン家
dvd プレイヤーがありません
2足あるじゃなためにあるいはちっ一日を
威力線が5着4マジコンですそれ
もちろんスプーン tvd 価格だして
るって俺と呼ぶあ
家
まっ
高いよねに吹い行ってくるっ
ええええええ
[音楽]
凄乳を飲んでですからね危ないと思い
ね
パターンファイルがあるのですよりもんな
んす金具6 pot がじゃないですか
って聞いて3つ
ブーバーしレトルト食器ですね気持ちいい
でしょ商品をまとめて買いますこのカップ
麺とのもつろんです4位レトルト食品
ぽい服鉱山装備でもボスして缶詰系も
すごいなが持ってるんでここらへんまとめ
て買います
態度 n ゲージたみてくださいをほぼ
なくなりました後はラングコーナーで
ございます子供たちの夢ゾーンですよ
ちょいちょい歳雑誌からすごいねーパズル
がはここ安産
あるねえ
ある
me
h aiaiai なかなか府が今に
こんな売ってることないんで普通の
コンビニに売ってそうな行だけかいます
この館によりまで俺は奪いたくない上で
ちょっとの常識範囲何買ってきませんここ
理由はもう避けなきゃいけだけだけだけ
じゃんお買い得ですよこれ顔れますがにお
買い得すぎるなあーっ ok 熱いなった
し為替もない明確持ってなかった彼は
感じろも好きだからそれは一番くじ所から
行かないといけないんだよ
ビックは何血管つっかいますこれくしょん
こんだけきますうしょうりみたいな使い
ますからね容赦願います俺もじゃあ今度
結腸からソンチャジャン球場8
下すございますまたおっ期待ますクリア
カードコレクションカム2個いきましょう
ん
[音楽]
普通のてポン子供に夢を与える店舗なんて
多いんでしょ玩具系が普通のコンビニに
ある宮も買わせていただきましたあとは
子供連れのために
残しおります線よるでつはすっかり
すっかりで街で朝から晩までたこれが最後
のトラック幻の映像ですね
はいというわけで朝から晩までずっとてて
コンビニの全てカッコタバコと子どもたち
の夢を除く全ての商品は買うことができ
ましたーーー
見て愛想もないら白いこんな一応ピンの
全てありません夢と急行だけ残すって
こちら雑誌も dvd もすべてないです
もうツバメの巣が足りません冷凍食品も
全部ないですハーゲンダッツもです
ジュースお酒も全部買いましたかっぺい
web 抜けました10年とか電池とか
そういうの全部でございました本当ござい
ましたあのある程度あったんすけど裏に
やりました3倍たために通貨また
ダーリングもすべてがいましたら部門全部
ありませんデザートももうない炎かしこ
アン起こっていると思っていました外に
窪んだ場所に切りもも弁当の全部なさ立つ
きっと下流税金ジュース野菜と肉で
スタンドもすべて
に切りました本当にめちゃくちゃ大変で
いろんな人のつからをお借りして富士に
すべて株ことができました
私の新居果たしてどうなっているの
でしょうか
コンビニあ俺オレンジコンビになっており
はこれこれ俺んちコンビになってリアない
と言うけど皆さんこう見えて僕の3億円の
新居でございます刈った量を考えるとこう
なることは目に見えてたんですけどもこれ
でもまだ全然一部です何となると色々置い
てみたなって感じなんでことがもう
コンビニでもこの絵も完全にねぇこっちも
飲み物多いよろ並べてみたんですけどこれ
はねー
今みんだねはいというわけで本日にんごと
買うとこういうことも平気で出来るんだ
なぁと改めて本日にの死なす言うの数の凄
さに驚かされました全然これで一部なん
ですよそ次これだけであの子部分ですよ中
でコンビニできるまで僕十分なんで僕が
使わないであろうものとかもちろん女性用
の生乳頻度が僕使わないんで一応品含め
食べ物と結構寄付したいと思います長持ち
するものとかもう俺はねコンビニができる
だけで十分です
というわけで金額の発表ですさあここが
ポイントだなんならここが過ぎたかッた
発表いたします
ここ俺まだ知らないんだよまずでねで終え
かなぎくんとかいる月とか手作りのお弁当
とかですね12704選んでパン類2番
1,844円
玩具カードと可能なアニメのいろいろが
40万円395円ちょっと待ってやばい
やばい雑誌
302,000682分衣類あのコーナー
ねあ電池となるともねえっ
37番6型313円
お酒
620,0007931集まったこれ
大丈夫ちょっと待って待ってドリンク
飲み物三世98,900円冷蔵食品
418,000281円エナジードリンク
9万290032冷凍食品5850027
位お菓子えっ
1,080,0007,154円
おっ化した核に保存食
125,00014円
[音楽]
日曜金利105万8,810円
これまずいぞ鯖ですねあの最初脳に変え
ました沢山の真っすぐで中¥11,266
全部買ってたら大変なことになってます
アイス
13万810022年サプリメント
¥23,320あのアニメとコラボしてた
カップ付きのゼリーはメっちゃったんです
よそれが
404,000な166円マン水ぞこれと
いうわけですべての59金額見てみ
ましょうなんかヤバい感じだな伝わったん
うん
ん
合計金額
560万960 star
うわぁ
高いよなコンビニでこんなお金使うん
だって思ったことがなくてちょっと想像を
絶しております車かえりゃー自分の口が
入らんけ高級車買えるぐらいの値段でした
ねコンビニまるまる買うと絶対全部自分で
食べれないと思うんでさっき言った給付は
もちろんなんですけどいろんなお菓子は
ですね僕と一緒に仕事してる仲間や友達と
みんなでちょっとずつ食べて弾み車の湯に
できたコンビニはぁ村を利用していきたい
とおもいます
yeah へ
ます
[音楽]
うぉっ
は
大きな問題を思い出しましたコンビニね
全部買ったのはいいんですけども賞味期限
っていうのがあって結構そのおにぎりとか
サンドイッチとかファーストフードとか
すぐ食べなきゃいけないんですよ
[音楽]
回主義一人定めるよねーすっ
みんな